a gente boa noite é eu procurei muito
uma uma frase pra começar a falar um
pouquinho sobre o que eu tinha 46 e é
uma frase de albert einstein escrita em
1922 é hoje ela faz muito sentido pra
mim mas há 10 15 anos até fazer muito
é uma vida calma e modesta traz muita
alegria traz mais alegria do que a busca
processo combinada constante agitação é
claro que em 2003 quando a gente começou
a fotografar onde surge começou estava
um momento que o mercado procurava algo
novo já era o mercado que as pessoas
buscavam fotografia a fotografia já se
vende um pouco na região e como uma
pessoa nova tanto eu como minha esposa
começando naquela hora nessa hora é o
agente tinha muita muita anseio em
trabalhar e fazer muitas coisas então
aquela frase por isso pra mim naquele
momento não fazia sentido nenhum a gente
queria trabalhar queria trabalhar muito
então a gente entrou com uma uma
linguagem diferente a gente tentou
trazer uma linguagem fecha o fashion
para os bucks pessoais
a gente já havia eu tinha um gosto muito
grande já artes desde música à pintura e
tudo mais
apesar de trabalhar numa área
completamente técnica quando comecei a
fotografar em 2003 a minha câmera como
muitos fotógrafos já começaram
era uma câmera uma lente mais nada e o
digital estava começando a gente tinha
uma câmera com menos qualidade com o
iphone tem hoje no bolso e muita gente
que está aqui
e os anos se passaram a gente conseguiu
trabalhar conseguiu conquistar mercado
com essa linguagem diferente essa
linguagem é mais fecham mais uma beleza
diferenciada eu sempre tive um gosto
muito grande pela fotografia sensual mas
até então não tinha me aventurando muito
nisso e também era uma coisa que era um
pouco tabu a gente mora numa região uma
cidade pequena sou de toledo
apesar de todo lado e cascavel muitos
clientes são daqui é uma cabeça já muito
diferente mas imagine como era todos
esses anos atrás
e graças a deus teve essa amiga nossa
eles que se propôs a fazer o ensaio com
a gente a gente acabou fazendo esse
ensaio para a playboy
inesperadamente dentro de vários
fotógrafos se inscreveram no brasil fica
em primeiro lugar o que foi assim uma um
salto na carreira uma coisa que
identificou no nosso trabalho ao longo
dos anos como a fotografia sensual ea
fotografia de beleza e tudo mais
usando os recursos continuarão seguindo
a gente continua trabalhando cada vez
mais sempre buscando mais é o preço da
fotografia um dos prêmios mais preciosos
que tem de fotografia no mundo é e foi
quando a gente estava fazendo um
trabalho em londres
eu recebi a notícia de que havia sido
não uma mas duas moedas a moeda de ouro
do primeiro lugar na categoria fashion
ea de bronze
tanto com essa foto que vocês estão
vendo aqui quanto conhece que foram
feitas no deserto do atacama no chile
todo o trabalho foi desenvolvido para o
agente desde o conceito da fruta foto do
que a gente ia levar para a viagem então
era uma coisa feita com muito amor eu
busquei muito por muitos anos buscando a
fotografia de moda por acreditar muito
nela e por ela dá essa beleza você
conseguir trazer uma coisa surreal para
a fotografia
essa mapa uma foto do making off
enquanto a gente fazia esse trabalho na
cama então a gente conseguiu viajar
muito graças à fotografia um parceria
com empresas daqui da região como a
máximos ateliê quebre escolhido por por
intuito nossa e por investimento nosso
também a revista investir com as
passagens mas a gente investir com a aam
com os custos de viagem tudo pra fazer
com que ficasse viável porque para nós
era bom fazer um portfólio então a coisa
foi crescendo foi tomando um ponto e é
claro quanto mais você viaja mais você
quer viajar mas você quer viajar mais
você gosta de viajar e eu acho que não
tem como você viajar assim você pensar
em uma coisa que une culturas e essa
coisa que une cultura ea culinária
então eu e minha esposa a gente sempre
gostou muito de fazer receber os amigos
em casa fazer um jantar diferente um
almoço diferente e esse do esse gosto
foi cada vez aumentando mais até que um
dia a gente estava num restaurante que
nos marcou muito e chama o som fica na
região de vinhos da nos estados unidos
napa valley é a gente decidiu não a
gente vai até então era um café mas
depois a gente mudou não a gente precisa
ter um restaurante mesmo a gente nem
sonhava com o tanto de trabalho que dá
hoje em dia se tivesse voltado atrás um
pouquinho talvez pensaria melhor mas
graças a deus deu tudo certo
daí a foto do nosso ministro em toledo
quem quiser conhecer clara de bistrô é
claro chegou nos primeiros anos tiveram
dificuldades como toda empresa os três
primeiros anos
tivemos várias discussões dos vários
problemas inclusive internos mesmo
dentro de casa entre eu entrei minha
esposa que realmente tocar um estúdio em
um restaurante foi uma coisa louca é eo
que acontece que a gente chega num ponto
e eu encontrei esse desenho na internet
acho que tem que correr pra falar pra
vocês
era eu lá e se nesse primeiro a lhe vou
fugir dos limites dessa caixa
eu era desenhista tinha salário ou muita
gente a levou a ficar livre para decidir
os próprios projetos de horários ou
abrir um negócio começar a construir um
negócio depende do conselho meu negócio
e eu me tranquei dentro do meu negócio é
igual o bonequinho ali ou não
e foi o que aconteceu ea gente realmente
tinha muito trabalho era uma sobrecarga
enorme
a gente acabou ficando quase sem ver
amigos em jantares para os amigos não
fazia mais por fim tudo vocês podem
imaginar
a outra também é um pouco da mesma
história é aquele momento que a gente
fica vendo o outro né principalmente
hoje colhe com a rede social com a
quantidade de likes e tudo mais né nossa
cara tem tanta coisa acontecendo cara
tentando flex também quero ter sucesso
com eles e mais tarde você está lá
afundado no trabalho ocupado ocupado
ocupado ou não e aí uma frase que eu
acho que diz um ponto em 2016 mais ou
menos de um minuto que você pensa que
você chegou lá é um momento que tudo
desaba porque é igual a comprar um carro
novo você se sente super feliz e de
repente você compra o carro mas depois
um mês ele só é mais um carro ea
felicidade vai embora é a mesma coisa
com as coisas que a gente conquista na
vida de certa forma a não ser as viagens
ou outro sempre fala de viagem três têm
um investimento que fiz na minha vida eu
não me arrependo são elas bom aí foi
quando em 2016 ou 2017 a gente decidiu a
gente já tinha um plano de ficar fora do
brasil por um tempo mas é óbvio que com
quase 15 anos de um estúdio fotográfico
mas quase cinco anos num restaurante
hoje não dá para simplesmente deixar
para trás
mas a gente tentou fazê lo de forma
menor então a gente decidiu vamos fazer
três meses
vou ficar três meses fora e encontrar um
novo sentido para as coisas a gente
acabou ficando três meses no canadá
eu fui estudar francesa já foi aprimorar
o inglês dela
tivemos algum trabalho alguns trabalhos
para fazer nos estados unidos também
mas foi nesse lugar no oeste do canadá
nessa região das montanhas viajando da
forma mais simples possível
com essas paisagens maravilhosas
dormindo dentro do carro por mais de 25
dias
às vezes não tinha a gente ficava o
acampamento que tem que tomar banho mas
é aí no mercado comprar uma comida de
mercado um ovo cozido pronto tem muitas
dessas coisas lá salada coisa assim a
caminhada 20 quilômetros um dia subir a
montanha pensar na vida
voltar a dormir no carro isso foi uma
coisa que foi fantástica que eles me deu
vontade de voltar pra cá minha vontade
dos meus amigos na vontade de ver a
família de montagem de mudar meu
trabalho minha relação com o meu
trabalho minha meta é que minha meta de
sucesso mudou então hoje eu diria que a
meta do sucesso pra mim é me perguntar
quanto vão viver me sinto mal quanto à
novidade eu coloco todos os dias na
minha vida todo dia que eu acordo com a
próxima aventura com a grande grande
projeto novo que eu posso colocar todas
as minhas forças
isso daí pra mim foi sair da zona de
conforto porque pra mim estava tudo
certo aqui pra que eu ia sair eu tava
tudo já funcionando
rodando é trabalho para fazer porque
deixa as coisas paradas aqui três meses
gastando dinheiro lá e gastando dinheiro
aqui pra sair da zona de conforto em
chegar com outros olhos
ontem mesmo quando está finalizando a
palestra eu vi essa foto que mais parece
um foi lá talvez interior de uma
pirâmide ou museu maluco muito velho
mas na verdade foi um fotógrafo teve a
brilhante idéia de colocar uma câmera
dentro do vilão shell e tirar uma foto
ela disparando a câmera com o celular é
fantástico ele fez vários testes com o
massa sem fumaça com luz vermelha como
amarela
eu nunca tinha visto nada igual havia
ontem foi nossa isso é uma coisa
diferente então enxergar o mundo de
outra perspectiva quando você sai quando
você deixa o tempo passar quando você
esquece do dinheiro das coisas que fazem
trabalhar com um maluco você para
enxerga com clareza chega melhor e traz
mais arte para as pessoas também é
obviamente se você não trabalhar duro
não fizer um bom trabalho as coisas não
funcionam
mas quando você faz um sucesso bem em
conseqüência o dinheiro vem bem as
energias nisso e não pensar nas contas
que vai ter que pagar o que você quer
comprar é na pessoa que está na sua
frente no seu cliente depende no entanto
independente da sua área porque é isso
que vai fazer você crescer como
profissional e não só isso como pessoa
porque o seu trabalho essa pessoa é quem
você é mais uma de notação sobre as
idéias às vezes a gente tem muita idéia
não faz nada por isso uma outra coisa
que eu digo é melhor você tentar é
melhor você fazer uma idéia mal escrita
o que mesmo não seja ainda coisa final
porque ela você sempre pode editar ela
você sempre pode melhorar depois
agora se você deixar tudo em branco você
não vai poder estar nada não vai ter
nada
então isso é uma coisa que achei que
valeria a pena compartilhar com vocês
e quando eu voltei de lá
foto que a gente fez um ensaio logo que
a gente voltou em setembro na praia
também normalmente praia aquela coisa
durante o dia então essa foto foi feita
na noite desta quarta feira à noite numa
câmera com uma exposição um vestido
tomou efeito de pintura as longas e tudo
mais uma coisa que eu nunca tinha
tentado antes e foram só aqueles dias lá
no canadá dormindo dentro do carro
olhando as estrelas que eu consegui
voltar e começar a chegar no trabalho
com outros olhares de novo e comecei a
amar fazer trabalhar - entre a mais
então hoje eu me sinto assim você nunca
chega lá está apenas constantemente
tentando ser o melhor ser melhor e fazer
algo novo
não adianta você vai sempre buscar mais
você vai sempre querer mais
graças a deus né por fim eu vou concluir
sobre essa frase que eu comecei de
albertazzi de 1922 ela foi escrita do
imperial hotel em tóquio é a sentava lá
no ano que ganhou o prêmio nobel de
física e ele ao invés de dar uma boate
uma gorjeta para o porteiro do hotel ele
escreveu dois papéis com essas frases
falou pra ele guarda que um dia isso
aqui não valem muito dinheiro mas o que
eu estou te dando hoje em outubro de
2000 e 17 a primeira carta que vocês
estão vendo aí foi vendida por 1,54
milhões de dólares que é a primeira
frase que eu comecei aqui
a outra foi por singelos 260 mil dólares
eu vou terminar onde há uma vontade há
um caminho albertão em 1922
boa noite
[Aplausos]